look at the number of times that you
promised that we would leave on the 31st
of October and you've broken that
promise just a few times just to use a
couple of examples and the 25th of June
you said we're getting ready to come out
on the 31st of October come what may
do-or-die right the 5th of September I'd
rather be dead in a ditch than delay the
16th of September we're going to come
out on the 31st of October we frost
anything you say when you work on your
promises because look at what we said we
did go back to where I was on the steps
of Downing Street 300 days ago and I
promised that we'd put 20,000 more
police officers on three so I promised
we'd upgrade 20 hospitals great New Deal
which people said was impossible
remember they said we wouldn't reopen
the withdrawal room wouldn't be able to
get out of the the thing that was
keeping the the UK back and we did plus
we got Parliament to say it was a good
deal but then they refused they refused
to implement it and actually Sophie
there was bags of time between that vote
to when they first said it was a good
deal and when they could have got us out
as well I do and I'm deeply deeply
disappointed and I had to consider yes
apologise to all those conservative
members who voted for you because they
thought that you would take them out of
the EU on the 31st to matter as a matter
of deep regret but what we need to do
now is get on and do it and the the
difference between this government and
any other party is that only this
government offers a deal that is ready
to go and a way of delivering it
immediately in the middle of December if
we're lucky enough to get a majority no
of course it's a big if and we'll be
working very hard but the the reason why
it's necessary to have an election is
because I'm afraid otherwise what was
going to have a parliament was going to
rope-a-dope us they were going to say
there
going to say okay you know we will agree
this will read that but they weren't
actually giving a final approval not to
buy New Year not by January the 31st and
then we would have had to go for another
extension and the reason why I'm so why
it's such it's so painful to have these
extensions it's not because of you know
my promises or my ego or whatever it's
because the uncertainty that it means
for the whole country businesses can't
plan families can't plan people just
don't know when brexit is going to be
done and that's that's why I think that
the offer from the Labor Party is so
crazy and so debilitating because what
they're saying is have another
referendum people what you're saying and
because people believed you when you
said that you take the UK out of the EU
on the 31st of October and when we last
spoke when you were pitching to be made
the leader the Conservative Party and
the prime minister we were talking about
your promise to leave on the 31st of
October and you said that if it doesn't
happen I think that what we'll face is a
political extinction and the
Conservative Party will suffer very
considerably from an electorate that
feels they can't trust politicians to
deliver one of those politicians who
people can't trust yet the circumstances
in which that happened it happened
because Parliament but and I said that
to you before Parliament may surrender
act which was a constitutional
innovation nobody had ever seen any kind
of law like that before
after what was passed what it required
what it required was the government of
the UK to go against its will to break
its own promises as you rightly
identified and to force the EU to allow
the EU to decide how long we had to
remain in the EU ourselves and that was
that was a total constitutional in my
view in abomination it was an innovation
it was not something that I could and
believe me when they when they came to
me Sophie and they said you know you've
got to I'm afraid you've got no choice
Prime Minister you know that
the been act the the surrender act means
that you've got to extend of course a
night the first time I filed it
vertically the letter I didn't want to
do it there's no way I wanted to do it
Donald Trump told LBC this week but
under your brexit deal we can't make a
trade deal with UK I'm afraid I wish to
cast any aspersions on the president
United Sates but in that respect to use
Peter Lee in error anybody who looks at
our deal can see it is a great deal and
what it does is it allows us to take
back control of our money our borders
and our laws but also okay but but also
it allows us to have full unfettered
control of our tariff schedules our
tariffs go after setting our tire
schedules in Geneva and to do it as one
United Kingdom and that is one of the
great things about that I stress that
deal is ready to go we've negotiated it
people said it wasn't possible but there
it is